sie haben die Aktivisten und die Vereine
die man verbieten kann und die jetzt
auch verboten werden man kann fragen
warum ist samidu nicht längst verboten
gewesen aber jetzt wird's wenigstens
jetzt gemacht hätte man längst machen
müssen aber das Schlimme sind ja nicht
die hauptaktivisten die man packen kann
und die man verbieten kann sondern diese
Breite von Menschen die auf die Straße
gehen und das mitmacht und ich muss
sagen ich habe mich auch lange um
Integration bemüht
äh es stimmt eine große Mehrheit denkt
nicht so aber
äh
die islamischen Verbände haben mich in
diesen Tagen tief enttäuscht tief
enttäuscht sie waren immer unsere
Gesprächspartner die türkische Gemeinde
hat klartex geredet gegen die Hamas eine
sekulare Organisation aber was Herr
masjek und der Zentralrat der Muslime
und andere haben überhaupt nichts gesagt
wenn die das nicht sagen ihren Gemeinden
dann ist die Chance alle zu erreichen
wirklich sehr
klein